he's the sort of person that the phrase
City Grandy was made for one of the
biggest names in British business for
the last decade and more chair of the
biggest Supermarket Tesco the biggest
house Builder Barrack development and
former president of the biggest British
organic business organization at the CBI
and then in May the guardian published
allegations about John Allen of
inappropriate behavior towards women and
he had to step down now he denies three
of the four allegations and he joins us
now for his first broadcast interview
since those claims thank you for being
on the program good morning
now honestly I thought quite a lot about
how to approach this interview right um
because we're only going to hear one
side of the story the people who've made
the allegations don't have a voice in
the program this morning and I do feel a
responsibility for that but at the same
time you know you also have the right to
put your side of the story across about
what you say happened and also frankly
you know you could have chosen elsewhere
to do it somewhere where you might have
got a softer landing on the program as
well so we appreciate that
um so when did you first find out about
these allegations I think it must have
been a couple of weeks before the
guardian published
they raised these issues they raised
these these very vague you know
unsubstantiated Anonymous allegations
and asked us if we wanted to comment and
I took legal advice and we did comment
made it very clear that as far as I'm
concerned there is absolutely no
substance in any of these allegations
I'm completely innocent and the guardian
you know notwithstanding decided to
publish we've asked them to supply more
information contextual information one
of the allegations is that some CBI
event in 2021
you know I said something that was
overheard and there was regarded as
being inappropriate actually I didn't
attend any CBI events in 2021 and that's
been independently corroborated now
let's I want to go through each of the
allegations
so there's four women making these
allegations the first one I I think you
admit did happen and that was in 2019
when you made a comment about a woman
who worked at the CBI indeed what
happened well I was it was a CBI
conference this was actually
chronologically the second I think okay
but um uh it was CBI conference uh
everyone was very busy I noticed that
one of the CBI staff was looking pretty
down in the mouth and I tried to cheer
up
um and clearly got it badly Wrong by
saying to her that's a very nice dress
you're wearing it suits your figure very
well
and far from being cheered up she was
upset by that as soon as I was told that
she was upset I sought her out I
apologized unreservedly Carolyn Fairburn
followed up to check whether my apology
had been satisfactory and was told it
was and that the individual considered
the matter closed why did that pop into
your head as something that would cheer
a woman up well I thought she was
looking a bit sort of miserable and you
know I would I wish to heck I had never
used the word figure now and I never
will again I think if I'd stop by saying
that's a very nice dress it suits you
very well I might not have got myself
into the difficulties that I I had but
it was well intentioned it was my
intention was to cheer up and obviously
I miss it was an ill-judged remark uh it
had the the reverse thing having said
that I've talked to many women I know
since then and most of them are
absolutely incredulous about how
somebody could be as upset as this lady
appears to have been with with what I
said did you not realize at the time
that she you'd upset no nothing about
her appearance at the time no reaction
she showed no sign no there was no
immediate reaction and I moved on it was
a very busy day as CBI conferences are
we have the Prime Minister the leader of
the opposition all sorts of other
speakers and I was cheering part of it
hosting and receiving uh the senior
political figures so this was a minute
or two during the course of a day do you
often make comments about women's
figures uh no
um not you know and it was and certainly
not since this particular incident I can
tell you
um uh uh and what I've learned I think
is the one has to be terribly careful
about what you say to people so so look
I put my hand up to that one I said
something with good intentions I
produced the wrong impact I've learned a
lesson from that I apologize for it
immediately at the time unreservedly and
I'm you know I find it interesting that
it crops up four years later in the
guardian now the other three you deny
absolutely May 2019 annual CBI dinner
when you were president it's alleged
that you touched a woman's bottom yeah
did you do that no absolutely not that
evening I was my principal Duty was to
host the chancellor of the excheco who
came along was our principal speaker it
was a very busy evening I'm absolutely
convinced that you know I did nothing
untoward uh during that evening or
indeed at any other time and you know
I've had lots of women writing to me
saying they've known me over 40 30 20 10
years and they have never seen me behave
in any inappropriate way towards towards
them or any other women and I don't see
why you know it seems very strange that
I should do that in as an isolated event
so no I absolutely deny it and there is
no evidence to support it it's also
alleged that during a Tesco shareholder
holder meeting in 2020 you again 22 22
you again touched a woman's bottom yes
again I absolutely deny that now Tesco
have investigated this thoroughly it was
allegedly a Tesco person as well who was
the victim of this particular
um incident they have written to and
contacted every Tesco woman who was at
that event including a number who've
left the company and and invited them if
they wish to complain either openly or
through a confidential whistleblowing
line there hasn't been Dickie bird from
that and indeed you know on the contrary
I've had lots of emails and letters from
Tesco women actually telling me that you
know they believe I behave very well
towards them in total so I've got I'm
absolutely convinced there is no
evidence support there that I'm ABS my
conscience is completely clear Sophie
the fourth allegation another CBI event
when it's claimed you made another
comment about a woman's dress that
apparently it was making it hard to
concentrate on anything else yes well
that's crystal clear that was allegedly
in 2021 I did not attend any CBI events
in 2020 and that is being confirmed not
merely by a third party inspection of my
diary not by me but also the CBI have
checked their attendance registers for
the all of the events in 2021 and I do
not appear on any of them so I as far as
I'm concerned that one's game set match
I guess what some people looking at this
might think is the allegations from four
separate people sound a bit similar
right touching buttons making comments
on people's appearances their figures
their dresses
what would you say to that well I think
it's it's interesting that they have the
the surfaced together in one article in
the guardian that after 50 plus years of
as far as I'm concerned as far as others
have perceived impeccable conduct
towards women suddenly this little
clutch of allegations appear uh in the
guardian I mean that does sometimes
happen though doesn't it right because
people have confidence in making
allegations if they know there are
others they think they're more likely
well that may well be true but I can
tell you each and every one of those
they're all quite separate each and
every one of those I've strongly defend
my my conduct there is no truth in them
and I'll tell you what I think is also
interesting and people have said to me
with more expertise in this field than
me Sophie is very often when some people
bob up then it gives others the
confidence to raise these now not a
single person has raised any other
allegations about me during the month or
two that this has been in the public
domain no one
um on the contrary you know I've had
hundreds of letters of support from
people who know me about a third of
which have actually been from women I've
worked with over many many years saying
that they think this is absolutely out
of character and they don't believe a
word of it now you've stepped down from
roles at Tesco and Barrett developments
do you think that's fair
well I think companies actually feel
under a lot of pressure when this sort
of thing happens and one of the things I
want to do over the months ahead and
it's not going to help me because
whatever damage has been done to my
reputation has been done that frankly is
I think we have to have a better way of
dealing with these sorts of allegations
that's fair to victims and I think it's
important because there are cases where
people are
inappropriately treated and I don't
think we should overlook that but also
fear to people who are accused that
there is some form of due process some
form of Investigation before judgments
are made about them now I think in my
particular case I think the companies
that I was chair of while seeing lots of
nice things about all the amazing things
I've done for them over the eight or
nine years I've been involved with them
frankly felt they had to be seen to be
do something and the simplest and
easiest thing was to propel me under the
the nearest bus
um now having crawled out from two
successive buses and still standing I
don't like to try I'm going to plan over
the next few months to talk to a lot of
people who know more about this than me
to sort of see if we can devise a better
way so that the next person who is the
subject of this sort of allegation is
more fairly treated But to answer your
question no I don't think I was
particularly fairly treated but
you know that's life I mean I'm not sort
of miserable about it I'm getting on
with my life now the backdrop of course
of this is wider claims about industry
particularly the CBI where there's been
some very serious allegations indeed was
there a toxic culture at the CBI not
that I was aware of I don't believe
there was and if there was I certainly
wasn't aware of it you weren't aware of
it because frankly you know you were a
white male in the senior position no I
think it was because my role at CVI was
essentially external representation I
spent time talking to government talking
to going around visiting the regions uh
including you know Scotland and Northern
Ireland quite frequently representing
the CBI internationally I wasn't
responsible for the day-to-day running
of the CBI that was the director General
and the management team but I certainly
saw no evidence over the time that I was
president of of a toxic culture I mean
do you think you should have looked a
bit harder you're the President right
yeah to Bear some responsibility for
things that were going on I look with
the benefit of hindsight probably yes
um but you know most of the allegations
of what took place were actually
subsequent During the period of during
which I was President I stepped down as
president in the middle of 2020
um when there wasn't much going on
anyway because if you remember for most
of us we were involved in lockdown at
that stage with a few notable exceptions
uh you know so there was no activity
going on at the CBI people were working
from home there were no events at that
time and certainly there was no evidence
I think that uh of you know untoward
behavior and I've talked to a number of
women in the CBI who I know and I'm
still in contact with who um actually
say to me that they don't believe there
was a toxic culture either but having
said that I'm not close enough to those
events Sophie to really give you a
authoritative view on the toxicity or
otherwise of the culture certainly
subsequently yeah it I wasn't also
interested to read an interview that you
gave in the Daily Mail where you said I
don't think men have always behaved well
towards women in the past patiently they
haven't the world is a much better place
than it was 20 or 30 years ago so what
was going on then well I think you know
if you go back there is no doubt in my
mind that you know that the many women
in business have actually been exposed
to inappropriate behavior by male
colleagues it may have been relatively
trivial or it may have been more serious
and I think the world has moved on
dramatically in terms of uh that now
being seen to be a to be seen to be
wrong and B people learning kind of not
to do it which is why I think did you
witness any of it
no but I have you know I had um uh I had
a very interesting letter from a someone
who's known me for a very long time who
said the following and this is someone
who I've known for 45 years who said
um I've known John Allen for 45 years
since the since the age of 22 and
working in the sexist and often misogic
misogynistic era of the early 80s while
other males were chatting up touching up
or putting down women John never said or
did anything inappropriate he was at all
times the most polite respectful and
equal-minded man I've ever had the
privilege of working with so look there
is no doubt I think and I was conscious
myself when I was a young CEO
occasionally women complaining to me uh
that they had been lent on by their
bosses somebody was told if she didn't
dance with her boss at a company party
it would be the worst for her I told
that individual you know he would leave
the company horizontally if he ever did
it again so I have no time tolerance for
people misbehaving towards women I think
things have got better I'm worried at
the moment that we might take a step
back because quite a lot of men say to
me they're getting increasingly nervous
about working with women mentoring women
something I've done a lot of Rights I
mean is that not real that could be that
sounds a bit sexist in itself but people
are saying that you know if they're
looking at a woman and the first thing
they're thinking is oh she's someone who
could put in a complaint about against
me I mean this is another form of
discrimination against women I think
it's a risk that that happens but I can
tell you that's what quite a few people
are saying to me and saying to others
that I know that they're going to be
very cautious uh in future about how
they they interact with women in the
market in the which is what women have
to do all the time which is you know we
shouldn't
yes but I think that I think if it leads
to over caution it will actually be
negative in terms of you know I think
women have made huge progress in
business over the last 20 30 years you
know I've been a part of that and I know
that I've played a major role in helping
increase the proportion of women on
boards for example and I would hate to
see that going backwards okay thank you
very much indeed thank you John Allen
there